I don't have slides and you might be
wondering why a neuroscientist is
standing up in front of you today at the
School of Social Work and this is
unusual but maybe not that unusual at
Columbia University
my name is Zoe Donaldson I am a former
RWJ health and society scholar here at
Columbia
I work as a postdoc in the department's
of neuroscience and psychiatry and I
think what dr. banana highlighted today
is that grief is actually a pretty
universal phenomenon at some point most
of us will lose someone we loved during
our life course and for most of us we
will eventually recover from that loss
however despite the universality of this
phenomenon we know almost nothing about
it at a neuroscientific level what
balances are disrupted in the brain in
the body that lead to an increased risk
for heart attack stroke mental illness
and a variety of other disorders
immediately following the loss of a
loved one in addition as he highlighted
certain individuals have hard time
recovering from this initial loss of a
loved one these people are said to
suffer from complicated or persistent
grief and we know essentially nothing
about the underlying neurobiology of
this what makes certain individuals more
likely to develop complicated grief and
what are the best most targeted
therapeutic strategies for these
individuals and so it's questions like
this that I think teams of psychiatrists
neuroscientists social workers and many
others can bring to the table and begin
to answer through the center so on a
personal level I'm honored to be a part
of this Center I did my PhD work
studying social bonding in an animal
model and I can say that at this point
we have a reasonable understanding of
the brain mechanisms that allow us to
form bonds with one another whether they
be people between mates between friends
between family members but we have
essentially no idea what happens when we
sever those bonds what happens within
the brain and so it's through the
beginning of this Center and with my
colleagues that I hope to begin to
examine this question using a monogamous
rodent species so my background as I
mentioned in social bonding was with
this same monogamous rodent species it's
in a new
usual laboratory animal the Prairie vole
so these animals will typically mate for
life they'll form strong selective bonds
with their mating partner and they'll
show a preference to spend time with
that partner they'll raise the offspring
together and sort of live this typical
home on the Prairie lifestyle and this
is in direct contrast with the majority
of rodents that we study in the
laboratory so both mice and rats the
ones that you read about read about in
the science section of the New York
Times don't form these bonds between
mates they're promiscuous and typically
just the mothers raised the offspring
and so we know the neurobiological basis
of this bonding behavior and voles and
now what we hope to do is disrupt these
bonds as a way to begin to understand
what happens in their brain
mechanistically underlying the behaviors
that you see immediately following the
loss of a loved one um as you can
imagine this wasn't pointed out earlier
but it's difficult oftentimes to
convince people to be research subjects
immediately after they've lost a loved
one and some people consider it
unethical to ask them at that time in
their lives to be part of a research
study and for this reason to get it the
most proximal mechanisms of what happens
when you lose a loved one I think that
prairie voles are going to be an
incredible useful model so for this
reason with the help of my colleagues I
really look forward to the studies that
we'll be doing in the next few years to
begin to identify translational
opportunities to understand the
biological mechanisms not own the
underlying grief but also complicated
grief I think this is a topic that's of
wide interest to many fields not the
least of which are psychiatry and
neuroscience and I think it's also a
testament to sort of the pioneering
spirit of Columbia that we're bringing
all of these groups together and to
Kathy for putting it together so thank
you